chị ơi đi một người thì gọi bao nhiêu đem lụi với cả
năm cây Cho em năm cây với một bún thịt nướng nhá
ngày thứ BA ở Huế của Tao đang đi ăn nem lụi
quán nem lụi này là quán nem lụi o đen
mọi người ở Huế recommend Cho cô ta ăn
quán này rất là nhiều ôi
bây giờ thì siêu siêu đói rồi nên là mình phải thử liền
mình có bánh tráng snack
dưa chuột hay là
ừm chua lắm đây là cóc non
quả này là quả gì nhở nó chất chất quả gì ờ cô ta không biết
một ít nộm và
nem lụi người ta làm cái nem lụi nó ấy
nó mỏng mỏng mỏng mỏng
không có tròn mình sẽ quấn vô nha
nấm mắm nêm đấy
cô ta thấy nó sệt sệt sệt sệt
mọi người Xin mời mọi người quá đói rồi
ừm ưm ừm cái nem lụi ở đây người ta nướng mỏng ấy người
ta cảm giác rõ là nó rất là giòn và ngọt
vị ngọt của thịt ý
và đặc biệt lại phải khẳng định là đến với mắm nêm rất ngon
oh my god cái rau mắm nêm ngon ý chấm định hợp
ừm
ừm ừm ừm ừm mình sẽ thêm một ít ớt trơn Cho nó tăng vị cay
ừm thêm vị ớt trơn mà nó cay nó cũng ngon
mà cô ta nhận Ra là người dưới ăn món
gì cũng phải hơi cay cay một tí
ừm còn o đen này thì chuyên nem lụi
bún thịt nướng với có cả bánh cuốn thịt nướng nữa
gọi 2 món Super chờ đấy là bún thịt nướng và nem lụi
bún thịt nướng nha mọi người ơi
bún
thịt nướng đây á
được Chan mắm nêm lên
và Tao khẳng định là mắm nêm ở Huế rất là khác
ăn nó thơm mà nó hòa quyện nha
trời ơi đồ ăn Huế